hello everyone and welcome to the
semi-finals of the video world team
championship it is um uh Uzbekistan
versus India Java crusindero versus Neil
sarin and this is one of the games that
you guys requested me to show uh it's
quite a nice one and it features a very
interesting finish to the game which
will also be used as a pause the video
moment so uh without further Ado let's
check it out uh a Joker with the white
pieces opens with E4 and interestingly
of course you guys know that Uzbekistan
won first place in the video Olympia
that was played a few months ago uh but
here they are playing without their
first board without their star player uh
but still doing incredibly incredible
work so syndrop opens with E4 yeah
replies with Ponte E5 Knight to F3
Knight to C6 and now Bishop to C4 with
Bishop to C5 and interestingly these are
rapid games in the previous video I said
that it was a classical event
uh because I thought okay feed the world
team championship that of course will be
a classical event but it's actually a
rapid event but still it's 45 minutes
per player so it it kind of is a lot of
time okay it's not classical but it's
not like a 15 minute rapid if that's um
uh what you were thinking and players
from Uzbekistan uh are 10th uh do tend
to play Demons again from time to time
so when I saw this I thought okay this
could be this could be it uh but nope uh
however we don't get the Evans Gambit
here we don't get the Joker piano which
is the absolute top move uh played in
the position but we get Knight the C3
which is even weirder because this is
the fifth most popular movie even after
the events game the Evans Gambit is the
fourth most popular move in the position
uh which is interesting before I started
my channel it was like the 15th most
popular movie you know in that position
true story uh so here Knight to F6 we
have D3 D6 and now uh you could continue
developing with with Bishop to G5 and
this is considered Best But Here Knight
the A4 attacking the bishop Bishop to B6
and now Pawn to A3 with H6 and H3 so
these are moves you will
uh most likely often see in every line
of the Joker piano except the Evans
Gambit we have castles castles and now
Bishop to E6 and here uh there are a few
games that reach this position there
there's even a game where a vladislava
team is defeated Shakira Madara with
Rook to E1 but here with Bishop captures
on E6 and it is now as of move 10 that
we have a completely new game f captures
an E6 and now Pawn to B4 uh a few moves
uh a bit late but better better late
than never we have Queen the E8 now the
queen can access the king side and pawn
to C3 and you have a structure that you
might see in an Evans Gambit decline for
example if white plays B4 attacks the
bishop and C5 and black goes Bishop back
to B6 then you might get some sort of a
pawn setup like this although okay the
pawn will probably be an A4 uh Knight to
E7 we have Rook the E1 and now Knight to
G6 and the piece is piling up nicely in
front of the white king Rook to A2 as
you do want your
uh second rank nicely defended and
rooked the d8 we have Knight captures on
B6 that Bishop is a monster so of course
uh Java will eliminate it a captures on
B6 and now Pawn to A4 that pawn on A3
was looking very weird Queen to F7
putting pressure on F2 but okay it's
already defended we have Knights the H2
now bringing the Knight to G4 and King
to H7 with G3 kawin to D7 and now Pawn
to C4 with full control over the D5
square but still D5 and okay Rook to D2
now if characters you can capture and
you will have
a nice attack on the black queen Rook to
F7 and now Queen to C2 with font to C5
and pawn to B5 closing off the queen
side and now uh okay the center is not
close the center uh can still be opened
uh but basically the breakthroughs in
the position are the C characters on the
5e characters on D5 black and also also
play characters captures although very
unlikely as The Rook will be attacking
the queen you can play A5 for some sort
of a future breakthrough in the position
and pawn to F4 and okay maybe even D4 uh
very unlikely it would take like like a
Mikhail tal he could make a d d for work
maybe uh but very unlikely
uh but okay Queen to D6 we have King to
G2 Rook D to f8 doubling on paneer file
and queen to D1 so yeah players just
testing each other no one wants to make
that um uh you know uh to go to the
point of no return Queen to D7 we have
Rook to F1 and now Rook to d8 we have
Queen to E2 and now Rook the A8 you
could also just Shuffle it back
to f8 Queen to D6 but look the A8 goes
after the A4 pawn and queen back to D1
we have Rook back to d8 and now Queen to
C2 Queen to E8 and now Rook the E2 and
here I guess uh nihal was already uh fed
up with repeating the position and
Uzbekistan won on board one a bit it
lost on on board one so maybe that even
happened before this game so uh maybe he
was forced to play for the win I have no
idea uh D character is an E4 he opens up
the position uh even though okay you
could still repeat it with Queen to D7
we have D captures on e4 and now Rook F
to D7 he claims the open D5 for his
Rooks we have rooked the E3
for the moment you can't really use the
D file okay you can use the D4 Square
not much to do there but all of the
other squares are taken by White's
pieces so here in Knights the H5 and
King to G1 you don't want Knight to F4
check to come Knight to F4 to come with
the check at any point in the future
Queen to F7 with Knight to F3 and now
King to G8 uh we have uh King to H2
Knight to F6 and now uh Bishop to B2
controlling this diagonal of putting
pressure on the E5 Pawn so here Queen to
f8 offering the E5 Pawn But First bishop
to C3 not not rushing with the capture
if you capture right away with Knight
captures on E5 uh then captures captures
and you lose control over the D2 Square
that's kind of a a kind of an important
Square now Rook to D2 attacks the queen
will put pressure on F2 and you are not
very happy here so instead after Bishop
to f8 uh Queen to f8 Bishop to C3 now
keeping an eye on that D2 Square and now
Knight to H7 we have Queen to E2 and now
Queen to F6 with King to G2 and now
Knight to G5 putting pressure on the
Knight here but just Knight back to H2
now you can play Knight to G4 put
pressure on the queen and you will still
be attacking the E5 Pawn from the G4
Square so uh Knight to F7 and now Pawn
to H4
Knight to f8 we have Knights the G4
attacking black queen queen to G6 and
now uh now you you could play with
Knight captures and E5 here but white
goes for a very tricky idea and that is
Pawn to H5 now of course if the queen is
captured then Knight to F6 check picks
up the black queen so after H5 uh we
have Queen to G5 and now Pawn to F4 and
now you can play uh Pawn to F4 with
Tempo and if you capture then you can
pretty much resign if captures captures
you've allowed white to open up this
diagonal and okay the queen can move but
Rook to G3 and uh well you will not be
able to survive this so instead after F4
we have Queen to E7 right away Ponte F5
going uh all the way Knight sorry
Knights the H7 and now even Pawn to F6
Black Thought okay I'm defending this
Square uh three times so F6 will not be
an option but that is exactly what
jovoker plays uh and the Knight captures
and F6 was played in the game in order
to survive these you have to play G
characters on F6 because the Knight here
is a crucial defender of the F6 Square
as you'll see because now after Rook to
F3 they're putting more pressure on the
F6 Pawn you can play King G7
and everything is fine if Knight
captures Knight captures uh Rook
captures is no longer an option for
example Rook captures an F6 okay black
gives up the queen but after King
captures and queen G4 you are very happy
here with black just Knight G5 and you
can hold this even Queen to F for check
King G7 Queen captures an E5 check into
H7 and you still have two Rooks for a
queen uh you are perfectly fine here so
that's the way to do it however in the
game nihal played Knight captures on F6
and now it's pretty straightforward
Knight captures on F6 G captures and
Rook e to F3 there is no uh Knight on H7
to support the pawn on F6 and King G7 uh
would simply be met with Queen to F2 and
now you can't really defend this there's
nothing you can do here if you try
something like Rook D1 it's a very
sneaky idea Rook captures an F6 now Rook
captures an F1 hoping for Queen captures
and queen captures and F6 there's the
in-between an ice fishing sug
six check King f8 and now Queen captures
an F1 and now white is just uh
completely winning you can capture here
you can capture here the Knight can't
move it's uh it's a terrible position
for black so after Rook e to F3 Knight
the G5 was played but now we have Rook
captures and F6 Rook to D3
uh putting pressure on the bishop also
the G3 Pawn might be attacked at some
point uh Queen to E1 defending the
bishop and now King to H7 not allowing
the capture of the H6 pawn bishop
captures on E5 and here okay if you play
Rook to D2 check you can just block Rook
1 to F2 and if captures just Queen
captures uh black doesn't really achieve
anything here so after a bishop captures
on E5 uh Rook the G8 was played and now
comes Queen to E2 attacking the rook and
it seems like it's uh not really the
greatest of moves uh because Queen to D7
defends the rook and now threatens Rook
the D2 to win the White Queen uh but
this is where it all completely
collapses for nihal feel free to pause
the video and to win the game for
jovoker uh while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
absolute brilliancy and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Queen captures and D3 I would do it in
slow motion but I don't like to do it in
slow motion when it's only one square so
Queen captures on D3 and he was in this
position on move 52 that nihal sarin
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh really brutal
stuff uh you're down a full rook and if
you capture the queen on D3 look at this
queen captures on D3 now Rook the F7
check you even give up The Rook Knight
and the King can't really go anywhere uh
as the bishop covers these uh two
squares so Knight captures an F7 Rook
captures an F7 with another check now
you have to play uh Rook to G7 now Rook
captures on G7 with check only square is
King to h8 and now you would play Rook
to D7 open up a discovery and win back
the black queen that was the point of
Rook to D3 try and force the black queen
to capture it and of course after a
forced King to G8 Rook captures on G3
that's it and uh well once uh the the
rule comes into the game black will get
checkmated very quickly uh there's even
uh a nice idea here you can just play uh
if King to F7 Rook to D6 or or anything
or Rook to D7 check and it will be a
quick Checkmate uh but yeah no point in
going all the way to there as after
Queen captures on D3 nikal resigned and
a spectacular victory for Java
kirstindarov and uh with uh board one
and board two winning uh let me just
quickly check how how they did on other
boards I don't want to trick you guys
onboard 3 but board four ended in a draw
between vakidov and sasikran and with
two and a half to one and a half
Uzbekistan has defeated India in the
semi-finals and now we have the finals
and we are also going to show a few
games for from the finals where uh China
will face the Uzbekistan and India will
face Spain for for third place and now I
can see that the games are already
finished but I don't want to spoil
anything as I do plan to cover the
finals uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh I would like to
thank Austin wheeler Ahmed Yousef
anupacal close box and Ubuntu Pang for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
video world team championship finals
until it finishes yeah so thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and did you
ever think that we would see a
continuation even rarer than the Evans
Gambit in that position so yeah see you
soon